hello lovelies today we are going to be
doing a what I eat in a day and I am
look excited about it
today's video is sponsored by General
Mills and Cheerios and I'm going to be
taking you through a very random eating
day PS I am pregnant and very nauseous
so excuse me if I only eat carbs today
now of course my general disclaimer that
what you're about to see is for
entertainment purposes only this should
not be taken as a prescription of how to
eat or even what I necessarily eat on a
regular basis every single day because
every moment every day every kind of
hour every week every meal is so
different just depending on what I'm
doing what I'm craving and obviously
just like what I have in the fridge so
take this as a fun little glimpse into
like a random workday and enjoy ok Oh on
that note let's do this
good morning everyone it's really early
here it's 4:50 in the morning which is
even early by my standards I didn't
sleep well last night because you know
when you've got to wake up early for
something important you just kind of
keep on making waking up a little bit
early before your alarm is it time yet
smiler I'm going to be off soon is it
gonna go off scene that's what I was
going through um you have to get really
super quietly cuz everybody is something
and I'm gonna hit the road today early
because we're going to Hamilton for a TV
segment so this is winter my friends it
is super dark outside it is a super cold
outside I'm just grateful that it's not
snowing right now because I hate to
drive a long distance in the snow I'm
not really hungry right now but I might
get feeling a little nauseous and hungry
on the way so I've got a big bottle of
sparkling water to get me started for
the day also just easy on the belly
things of banana and a Clementine which
are my favorite things in the world
right now so alright let's let's let's
get going
alright so I just arrived they quickly
did my makeup I'm gonna go just straight
my hair a little bit get myself
completely dressed and ready to go and
then it'll be Showtime very hard to do
this with the opposite hand and
backwards really not doing much here
alright and my amazing stylist is just
getting everything ready here so this is
what its gonna look like when it's done
still lots to do so I got to finish this
up okay so I am pretty much all ready to
go I'm just gonna take a little
breakfast break and sit down for a
second while my stylist finishes up the
table I've made myself some tea it's
just a nice herbal tea I don't ever have
caffeine before a TV segment but
definitely not well by hand
I've also got some hard-boiled eggs I'm
going to try to have a little bit of
protein and I made myself like a
breakfast how much kind of thing with
some whole grain sourdough some natural
peanut butter and some cherry chia jam
that I made and I put a little bit of
hemp parts on top as well for some extra
extra nutrition so that I'm really
looking forward to so good okay so I
really could only stomach like one of my
two eggs but now I'm seeing this like
tiny little piece of one of my favorite
Tim Hortons doughnuts it's a chocolate
glazed doughnut so I'm definitely going
to crush that right now
[Music]
well barely survived that one um not my
best segment because I thought I was
like legit going to throw up and I kind
of had to like coughs last choked it out
on camera so that was really fun but I'm
gonna go get myself home and do a little
workout and yeah I might have a snack on
the way so we'll see how I'm feeling I
the last time I remember throwing up in
my first pregnancy it was coming home
from Hamilton so let's hope this isn't
going to be a repeat oh well I finally
am here at the gym and honestly every
single time I come home from Hamilton
it's like Waze takes me on a tour of the
GTA and icy regions of Toronto and the
outskirts of Toronto that I have never
seen before so it's always a little bit
of an adventure I'm starting to feel a
little nauseous again thankfully may
have to drive without throwing up so
that's a win but I think gonna try to
eat the other egg that I left from
earlier and I think I have a Clementine
as well that I might have a little snack
on I'm also thinking about getting a
Starbucks because I have a few minutes
so I'll see how I'm feeling after at the
egg the thing about this day sickness
I'll call it it's literally all day and
all night and all morning and everything
is that it's really kind of gotten me
back in touch not that I've ever been
out of touch recently but really forced
me to definitely be mindful in my eating
really kind of shake up the routine
because sometimes I can't eat a normal
sized meal that's something that I would
have otherwise in the past had for a
specific meal or a snack so I've had to
eat a lot slower check in with myself
multiple times because I will feel
really sick when I don't eat and then I
eat and if I literally have one bite
too much I feel even more sick so it
really does force me to slow down so
juicy you can see the spritzee's coming
off
yom-yom so that was an awesome workout I
am kind of obsessed with Legree it's
slow impact which I love and it's really
great for not getting a hurry too high
and typically it is pretty like core
intensive so I just kind of will modify
some of the moves that I can't really do
in this state so usually I'll just do
something else more leg work or
something but yeah today was a real
glute heavy day so I am definitely going
to feel this tomorrow and even though
I'm like so tired from just not sleeping
great I always feel really so much
better after I do some form of movement
doesn't have to be extreme you don't
need to do any kind of like crazy boot
camp but just that like a little bit of
gentle exercise I feel so much better
all right so back from the gym I feel
great I feel so much more energized now
and even though I'm not doing like a
super crazy hard workout I do still try
to get a combination of protein and
carbohydrates after a workout that's
just going to aid in recovery so today a
quick little snacky snack I've got some
Greek yogurt for protein I'm also going
to a swirl in some powdered peanut
butter cuz I love the peanut buttery
flavor but also it's really high in
protein as well go top it off with some
frozen blueberries which are gonna thaw
in like a hot minute I've also got some
of my cherry chia jam which I also put
on my little sandwich breakfast sandwich
this morning I will leave the link below
for this recipe it is a recipe that I
probably make every single week for
myself and for baby II oh this is like
Big Boy now but anyways it is delicious
and also ham parts and of course some
original Cheerios because I'm a big fan
of a good crunch factor but I also love
that it's low in sugar and a whole grain
cereal so I do try consistently to
choose whole grain cereals rather than
refined grains because of the extra
fiber and Newt
which we know is really important for
regularity satiety heart health and
blood sugar management and I think
there's a lot of misconceptions about
serials being inherently really high in
sugar but there's actually a lot of low
sugar options out there that make it
really easy for us to get in more whole
grains now a lot of people ask me how do
you know if something is whole-grain
well basically you want to look at the
ingredient list and what you want to are
looking for is the words whole-grain
they should be right at the top of the
ingredient list so you can see with
Cheerios it is the first ingredient so
not whole wheat not multigrain not
enriched grain you want to look for the
words whole-grain and actually General
Mills products also now have this really
easy to spot blue badge on the front of
the package which just makes it even
easier to spot a whole-grain option so
let's make a little balanced breakfast
bowl we're starting with some of that
Greek yogurt you can also use a
plant-based yogurt if you prefer a
little powdered peanut butter which we
love baby loves us to add is that peanut
butter flavor and it's really high in
protein so oh I'm already making a mess
oh dear
it's literally like peanut butter mousse
like this this on pancakes is so good
[Music]
the hands problem
[Music]
and Hoth's looking very stained gonna
wash my hands but that is the final
gorgeous snack bull okay mmm I'll get
some of that chia jam some of the people
peanut butter yogurt and all those
Cheerios
[Music]
baby II would love this I think he's got
a playgroup right now so I might have
Stephen just like a little taste for
like a pre nap snack or something cuz
this is this is really good okay so this
is pretty much the end of Matt Porter
from I've saved a little bit for baby
Eve um I'm going to go have a shower and
attempt not to get my hair and makeup
wet you know because I just washed it
yesterday so blonde problems and then we
got a lot of work to get done today so
let's get to it okay so I got a lot of
emails that I got to get through a
conference call in about ten minutes
so I'm gonna get started on that but if
you're wondering why I'm glowing it's
because I use this this kind of si D sad
light therapy lamp while I'm working
not so much for sad but more because I
do find it helps with my circadian
rhythms and helps with sleep a little
bit and since I started using it I've
actually been sleeping a little bit
better and that was like my discovery
after I came home from from Florida
where the Sun was so bright and I was
having the Sun all day and then at
nighttime of course would be dark and
not just position seemed to really help
my sleep so I thought I would give it a
try at home and it's kind of working so
I'm gonna keep up with that but I'm
going to get to my emails okay so um I
had a long conference call wrote a blog
post and did a lot of email answering
and I feel like it's time for some lunch
so I am feeling like soup that is
basically all I feel like now because I
know no joke this morning sickness thing
is a big fat lie because it's an all-day
sickness and as a result I don't really
feel like eating anything super heavy
and soups just feel good to me right now
so basically every
the weekend I make a big batch of soup
and this week I've got some split pea
soup in the fridge so very excited to
get into that it's like one of my
favorites and of course I want to have
like some bread with the soup and I
thought why don't I like boost the
nutrition of the bread and we make like
an avocado toast to go with it so I'm
going to make a cheater easy version of
the avocado toast that is in the mindful
Glo cookbook if you don't have the
mindful Glo cookbook friends you need to
get it it is I'm going to leave the
description on the link in the
description below it is I mean I know
I'm biased but it's really great so this
is the avocado toast that is in the book
we're gonna do a much lazier version
than that in fact I'm not even gonna get
the food processor out because my kid is
sleeping and it's loud and I don't want
to wake him up never wake a sleeping
baby even if it means you know a less
beautiful less Instagram a bowl lunch so
what we're gonna do for the avocado
toast is I've got some white beans that
I just kind of drained and rinsed I
don't need the whole cans worth just
because I'm making this blingy and maybe
a little bit for baby II so I'll just
put a few of them into the bowl and
we've got an avocado here and I think I
won't get me like half the avocado I
don't need to go crazy I'm gonna cut it
on the board because avocado hand is a
real thing my friend and there are a lot
of doctors out there if you talked about
how in the ER a lot will come in with
like sliced hands because they're like
cutting their avocado in their hand that
is dangerous I just realized like it was
scary what I was just doing so don't do
that um we're gonna let you see what's
going on here
all right we've got our white beans I'm
gonna mash them up like I said normally
I would put all of this into the food
processor but it's noisy so let's not do
that
let's try to be
so my sweet little babe can enjoy a long
luxurious 3-hour nap
wouldn't it be nice wouldn't that be
really nice I mean as you can tell I'm
like to talk to quietly because I don't
want to wake that sweet boy so I'm just
gonna matched it up not anything
beautiful adding in the avocado half
here to this is gonna really boost up
the avocado toast because I find yes
avocado is amazing it's rich in fiber
it's rich in healthy fats there's no
protein here so I feel like I need a lot
of protein to just feel my best so I
just figure we'll throw into some of
these white beans and just boost it
right up I'm also gonna add in a little
squirt of so you can see like normally
like in the book it's super super smooth
and pureed but this is what its gonna
look like here a little bit of lemon
juice of course to prevent browning and
also add in a little bit more flavor I
love I love any kind of acidity and I
failed all right
so that's that's gonna be our filling I
mean you could totally eat this in fact
I'm gonna save some of it because I feel
like my kid is gonna want to just like
eat it by the spoonful but you can also
like smear on a little bit of toast as
like a breakfast or a snack it's really
good
so Tostitos this is that amazing the
whole grain sourdough that I've had for
breakfast and it's so good do we always
look forward to
mmm okay I'm gonna toast it okay here is
some of the split pea soup which mmm
still smells so good I sometimes find
that split pea soup it kind of
gelatinize this and like thickens up a
lot in the fridge as it sets so if you
find it's too thick if you've made like
a big batch and it's too thick when you
go to reheat it you can always add like
a splash of stock or just like a little
splash of water and pop it in the in the
microwave or if you're reheating it on
the stovetop or whatever it just helps
to loosen everything up a little bit
all right load on some of this avocado
throw in some tomato and a sprinkling
photo and purse and I'm gonna top mine
off with some crunchy chickpeas as I
sold like a coupon so good I'm very
excited to have this
[Music]
papi papi sent her in her lair did you
see her papi do you want tomato good
girl okay so I think I hit my maximum
you can see I almost finished my soup
and I almost finished my toast but it's
like one bite too much and I feel really
full so gonna take it easy
drink some water answer some more emails
I've got another blog post I have to
write then I promised myself / baby II
though he doesn't even know that I'm
going to make him his favorite muffins
today so that's on the agenda that has
to happen and so I gotta get through few
through a few things first but it's
gonna we're gonna get there I can't even
be bothered to go up into my office
where my sad light is because I just
feel like I'm gonna come right back down
here in like a hot minute just to to
cook those muffins so I'm just gonna
hang out here at the breakfast bar for
the rest of the afternoon okay so I
pulled up my recipe from my blog and I
realized I'm missing a few ingredients
so we're going to freestyle a little bit
basically it's not a big deal I'm
missing two of the eggs so I've got some
flax eggs sitting in the fridge just
glue ping up as it does and I don't have
any baking powder here I guess it's all
at the studio and we have baking soda so
I'm gonna a makeshift baking powder by
mixing together baking soda 1 part
baking soda with two parts of cream of
tartar so that's we're gonna do but
let's make these muffins they are one of
baby's favorite snacks they're peanut
butter and butt
I'm gonna use blueberry though in the
recipe that I wrote it's with cherries
but I don't have any more cherries cuz I
used them all in the cherry cheese um so
I've only got some frozen blueberries
and they are going to be delicious
so well let's get making some muffins
okay so first of all we got some bananas
I've got some microwaving in the fridge
but any time I have extra bananas I
literally pop them into a freezer bag so
that I can pull them out anytime that I
need the like I've got a recipe that
calls for really ripe bananas and I
don't have any that are perfect my
freezer always does so that's what I've
got going on right now
okay so first I've got my peanut butter
just a quarter cup but you could use
almond butter or cashew butter or
whatever you like best then I've got my
ripe bananas I'm gonna measure these I
need two and a half cups so hopefully
I've got enough I've got an already dead
one here that's gonna go in as my last
half cup normally you do three eggs but
because I've only got one egg left I've
got two flax eggs in the fridge I'm
going to add those as well I also forgot
that I don't have melted butter so I'm
going to have to find some coconut oil
so just bear with me you styling it is
these are gonna be mainly plant-based
today and I think I'm going to use that
ball of my oil all right
close enough
[Music]
it's cold out here
so I'm going on a quick little walk see
here and I'm going to actually get a
blood test because I'm in a point of my
pregnancy where I'm able to do something
called the mi PT which is an early
genetic screening test so I'm going to
go get that done today usually actually
at this stage you can also find out the
sex of the baby if you want but we are
going to be leaving that to a surprise
because that's what we did last time and
we really enjoyed that so yeah then I
get my blinds drawn and I'm already out
of breath oh my gosh pregnancy
why I'll catch you when we get back home
oh okay so that was a quick little trip
wasn't too bad so when as I plan I have
to wait like forever at those labs but
it was really not busy I guess going in
the middle of the day is actually a
really good idea most people probably go
before work or after work so that's the
nice thing about having my flexible
schedule but trudging in the snow made
me a little bit not just a little bit
hungry so I thought this would be a good
opportunity to get some veggies in I'll
be totally honest being pregnant in
these first few months have definitely
not made me want to eat a whole lot of
raw vegetables so normally I'm a big
salad eater I like always have at least
like one salad today I love salad I love
greens I love the crunchiness I have had
a hard time finishing a salad the past
few weeks but for some reason I got home
and I was like craving cucumbers so I'm
gonna have some cucumber and some
carrots with some tzatziki I love to
Zeki and my son also loves to see he so
we always happen in the house I didn't
feel like eating raw carrots so I'm
eating babies like steamed baby carrots
they say don't like mmm I love baby
carrots hence why my hands are orange
everybody likes to point out I don't
know why I don't even eat that
many baby carrots and you know sweet
tales I really don't don't eat them
everyday but for some reason I'm just
super sensitive and my hands turned turn
very orange whatever that's just me I'm
gonna keep eating the healthy fruits and
vegetables that I love anyways I'm going
to try to get some veg in and I'll see
you after the workdays over I think I
needed some more water so this is
helping also to all the pregnant ladies
out there who are in the first trimester
and you guys are literally just like
eating chips all day and you feel really
super guilty about it worrying that like
your baby's gonna be unhealthy or are
you doing something wrong just know that
it doesn't really matter
do whatever you have to do to survive
these weeks honestly there's no
judgement and and honestly whatever
feels good to your body is what's best
for you and baby your baby will live
literally take any nutrients that you
have in your body first so don't worry
about baby not getting enough I'm pretty
confident that that in most cases it
will try your best to nourish yourself
as much and as often as possible so I
find that those smaller kind of meals
feel best to me but of course go with
what works for you and your body but you
know just just test it out it takes a
little bit of experimenting I've really
found that my normal meals and my normal
meal sizes and my normal meal times have
not been working for me and so I've
really just been letting my body be my
guide so trust it even if you feel like
it's telling you the wrong things you
just got to get through these weeks and
I promise you probably I mean I'm trying
to promise myself this by sometime in
the second trimester you will be feeling
a lot better and you'll be feeling like
eating vegetables again
and you won't just want to eat better
and toast every single meal all day
every day so there is a light at the end
of the tunnel and by that time you're
gonna be like I'm so craving a good
salad that's what it was like for me in
my last pregnancy and actually with my
last pregnancy I also really did not
feel like eating meat so that's been
like a really big theme both times
not a big meat-eater don't really feel
like I totally went off fish
I couldn't eat fish I couldn't eat
chicken like for my entire pregnancy I
really just had eggs and a lot of beans
and pulses and things like that so that
seems to be what's working for me again
this time so I'm gonna keep at it
because that's really kind of being the
theme like that the road I've been going
down anyway so yeah a few little few
little thoughts while I enjoy my veggie
snack I'm gonna use this time to to
respond to some of your lovely comments
on on my youtube channel
most are lovely some not so much
but I just ignore those mom time oh ok
so baby E is playing in the den for now
I feared I'm going to make some roasted
broccoli I just have had a hard time
eating a lot of vegetables but I'm I'm
kind of craving some kind of like
roasted broccoli with like you know some
balsamic flavor I don't know I just I
like the Tang eNOS that's really what's
appealing to me right now
so it's we're gonna keep it super simple
because I have about 30 seconds before
somebody starts screaming mama at the
top of his lungs I'm going to show you
how I'm gonna do this so I've got my
baking sheet and the oven is preheating
to 400 degrees or so at the beginning of
the week on like Sunday I take any of my
produce and I'll chop it up it'll just
save me so much time during the week
when things get crazy and my mom
actually showed me these little produce
bags so don't you think she needs an FC
shop
I keep telling her she's such a Martha
Stewart anyways those are going down and
then because I'm super super lazy I have
some leftover balsamic vinaigrette that
is really really good it's made with
like a really rich aged syrupy balsamic
vinegar and lots of little bit of olive
oil and lots of Dijon mustard so I'm
actually gonna toss it in that cuz I
feel like it's gonna keep it
caramelized really really good so that
is probably good 20 oh I hear the little
one all right I need some kind of
utensil one second I think that's good
so let's do a little pepper and a little
salt I'm gonna pop these into the oven
okay so I was going to make something
for dinner from scratch but today has
been the longest day of life so I'm over
that also my husband is in Vegas right
now so I'm single parenting the child so
no I'm not gonna be cooking again
especially because we have so many
leftovers in the fridge because we did
like a big huge kind of recipe testing
day this week so I have this amazing
vegan I'm calling it like a Beefaroni
which I mean is very nostalgic for me I
don't know if you guys grew up eating
canned Beefaroni but it was definitely a
staple in my house and this recipe
turned out so good baby II loved it I'm
very excited to have a fifth portion of
it tonight so I guess that's what we're
gonna be having so I have no idea how
much I'm gonna end up being able to eat
the theme with dinner these days is that
my eyes are tending to be bigger than my
stomach so I just feel really full
really fast so we'll see how I do
tonight but I love the idea of pasta
that's like totally what I'm craving and
also the fact that there's some
obviously it's my really good protein in
here from the the meat the meat right
the soy-based meat which is what I used
and so I'm gonna leave a link to the
recipe below it's so so good but
basically it's like tomato sauce the the
soy beef cooked some chickpea pasta for
extra protein which is always kind of my
go-to pasta some spices but it's really
super super easy and simple and I'm
gonna add a little sprinkling of like
Parmesan cheese you could do like
cheddar cheese or you could do a vegan
cheese if you are completely plant-based
so that's gonna be my portion and I've
got baby ease dinner here and I'll give
him some of the roasted broccoli when
it's out of the oven and cooled down so
looking forward to that is my dinner and
some broccoli we'll see how I do we'll
see how I do
and baby eats me off I've got a few
extra standbys in there in just in case
he's like not feeling the Beefaroni and
wants to just eat like lots of
vegetables which I'm also okay with all
right end of the day finally watch on
your pasta you can use your fork too you
can usually for like mop fork like mummy
mmm I mess vegetables and these roasty
at balsamic veggies mmm so good you have
some broccoli to you're gonna try that
yeah I like mommy happy you enjoying
your your dinner - I really do find that
kids eat so much better when you're
eating the same things as then any time
that I have something different on my
plate that he doesn't have he legit
freaks out he will cry like the entire
meal until I go to him and usually the
only reason why I have something he
doesn't is because it's like super spicy
and I know he's not going to like he'll
cry but you know he's crying anyway so
sometimes I just give it and let him try
it and then he can learn from himself
for himself right that's that's my
parenting strategy yeah you like the
broccoli yummy - yeah but I got lots
more okay I can tell he's starting to
get really
distracted by this camera thing that I'm
speaking into and I'd love to continue
to eat with you guys but I'm gonna enjoy
this family time and I will see you
after dinner I guess if I can stomach
any little snacks and Italy's okay bye
alright folks I am going to kind of
begin my nighttime routine I'm gonna
wash my face I'm gonna take all my
supplements so I'll show you what I'm
doing right here basically but not too
many right now actually I used to take a
lot more and if you guys are interested
I can do a whole video about all of my
supplements in my fertility journey but
anyways I'm taking right now omega
threes prenatal vitamin D and this is an
NAC which has there are some evidence
for Rhea current loss so I continue to
take that until 20 weeks I've also got
to take pepcid which is part of my
regime and claritin which is also an
adjunct for my IVF and routine my
progesterone suppositories for a few
days and then one more estrogen patch so
I'm weaning off of a lot of these dress
which I'm very excited about and those
are the ones that I have to take still
so let's get cleanup
just realize I have roughly my teeth so
that's cool I'm really good swallowing a
lot of pills down to just one which is
so awesome okay so to close off the day
I'm gonna watch some TV you know I hear
that baby E is asleep which is awesome
and yeah I usually watch something
that's like really mindless and easy
something that's not stimulating and can
help me just like relax after a long day
I also always have like a little bedtime
snack and one of the things I've learned
or the past few weeks is well I used to
have like kind of like a nice like bowl
of ice cream or you know something like
that usually I like I like ice cream I
just can't do really sweet creamy things
right now doesn't sit well with me and I
just don't crave it at all so I've been
going to for either more savory snacks
like popcorn or toast or cereal
something that's really easy on the
belly because this is obviously this
actually is the time where I feel
usually the most sick in the days is in
the evening I don't know if it's like a
tire thing but that I do find that it's
a correlated to just my exhaustion so
tonight I'm having a couple of these
little mini muffins and I'm gonna leave
the recipe for these in the description
below because they are a staple in our
home we make them like once a month and
I freeze them all like a ton of them
they're all in the freezer right now
baby he had two of them after dinner and
I was like oh I really want one by one
er so um now I'm gonna have a couple
right now also just so you know I ate
all my broccoli and it was really really
yummy and I'd so enjoyed it I uh I've
been craving vegetables but I just like
in a lot of these situations and meals I
just haven't been able to stomach them
so I'm really happy that they tasted
really good to me today
so that was what I was feeling I'm gonna
enjoy these did they do it I also if
these if I'm still hungry after this
I brought some pistachios out love
pistachios but I'm not sure I'm going to
finish them all but they're really
satisfying so I do find I need a
satisfying bedtime snack regardless I'm
probably gonna wake up in the middle of
the night and need to have some crackers
because I usually feel nauseous
and starving at like 3:00 in the morning
so I always have some crackers by my
bedside but after it have my snack I'm
going to brush my teeth I'm gonna take
my magnesium calm drink which is just
like a powder supplement that I take for
relaxation and for sleep and I am going
to hope that I fall asleep really fast
tonight because you guys know I'm a bad
sleeper and I did not sleep well last
night and I'm really really tired so I
need a good sleep so yeah let's hope
that tonight is a really good sleeping
night well friends that is all for today
if you enjoyed my little what I in a day
while pregnant and very nauseous please
give this video the thumbs up leave me a
comment below with any other youtubers
that you want me to some review when it
comes to their wedding in two days
any thoughts you had any questions I'm
also gonna be doing a kind of Q a
pregnancy edition so be sure to leave
your questions for me about that also a
big THANK YOU of course to General Mills
and Cheerios for sponsoring this video
and of course if you liked this don't
forget to subscribe and I will see you
next time on Abbey's kitchen bye
[Music]
[Music]